one thing we all know is that there is
no trauma quite like a Tick-Tock trauma
those traumas inflicted on and
documented by Tick-Tock influencers and
used by those same influencers for
social media Cloud are by far the worst
traumas known to man nobody in the world
has ever known the sort of suffering
that this group of poor unfortunate's
experience every day of their miserable
lives case in point take Tick Tock
vlogger Jessica who went viral over the
past few days after posting a video to
her 600 000 plus followers revealing the
purported sexual harassment that she
encountered at the gym she also posted
the video to Twitter along with this
caption this is her caption she said
this guy kept making me extremely
uncomfortable at the gym this is why
I'll end up crying on stream because I
feel so grossed out at times with the
amount of sexualization I experience
hopefully this spreads awareness for
girls who experience this type of
treatment at the gym
in the thread below the video she
further explains that this man was
staring at her for quote disturbingly
long periods and that this triggered her
quote fight or flight response and
conjured up memories of quote previous
traumas
she emphasized that she's tired of being
sexualized and just wants to work out in
peace without anyone watching her
it sounds like
whatever happened exactly it was pretty
terrible I mean obviously this guy at
the gym he's a pervert and a creep he's
lurking off in some dimly lit Corner
staring conspicuously at her
that must be the case because the only
other possibility is that this woman is
a narcissistic drama queen and a liar
looking for ways to entrap innocent men
so that she can slander them on the
Internet for clicks and that just
doesn't sound like anything that any
woman on Tick Tock would ever do but
let's consult the actual video just to
find out here it is
this is how to not approach girls at the
gym
because I hate when they're sweet ass
it's me so uncomfortable
several cell feral feral like feral
there's mirrors everywhere so it's like
you can easily cat catch people
oh this is nothing
okay we're gonna move on to the 35 now I
want you to watch very carefully
yeah it's the five as five pounds
excuse me you don't have to do that it's
okay no no it's okay I got it thank you
though
ah okay so
he glances over in her Direction a few
times for less than like half a second
at a time and then finally walks over
and tries to help her put the weights on
the bar and she declines his help and he
says okay
and then he walks away the end and they
all live happily ever after well I mean
he does maybe but she walks away
traumatized crying and shaking barely
able to hold herself together because a
man briefly noticed that she exists
now before we analyze this incident one
thing you should know is that this video
is one installment in an Ever more
popular genre on social media there are
apparently many videos of men quote
harassing or quote staring at women at
the gym these incidents are usually
captured in the same way there's a woman
at the gym filming herself working out
for whatever reason and in the process
she catches some man in the background
quickly looking in her Direction she
isolates the clip post it to the
internet and then shames the offender
for his conduct
here's just one more recent example I
got some attention a couple months ago
of this sort of thing as I said there
are many others where this came from and
this one a tick tock influencer named
Adriana claims to have captured footage
of a gym employee quote being a pervert
and gawking header while she takes her
shirt off and you may ask well what the
hell are you doing taking your shirt off
in the middle of the gym we'll get to
that in a second but um anyway here's
the video
and up for myself he threatens to call
the police and revoke my membership
thank you
sometimes
do you need something
do you need something do you need
something
okay I thought so
[Music]
um
this is why we need sex segregated gyms
we just do like male and female gyms uh
that that's a solution to all this stuff
because so many times no man at the gym
been to many gyms in my life and men are
not looking for any kind of drama at all
they're just there doing their thing and
they're not looking for any of this just
like if you're there and you want drama
and gossip and you're looking for
problems and you want to leave and have
something to talk about to your friends
well guess what happened at the gym no
man wants to leave the gym with that
kind of story guess what happened at the
gym
that's something that some women look
for and so we just need to be in
separate ships just do your own thing
that's what we need have you ever read
the fine print that appears when you
start browsing in incognito mode it says
that your activity might still be
visible to your employer your school or
Internet service provider to actually
stop people from monitoring your online
activity you need to do what I do and
get the only VPN you should trust
expressvpn think about all the times
you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee shop hotel
or even a friend's house without
expressvpn every site you visit can be
logged by the Admin of that Network
that's uh still true even when you're in
incognito mode expressvpn is an app that
encrypts all of your network data and
reroutes it through a network of secure
servers so that your private online
activity stays private like it should
expressvpn works on all of your devices
and it's super easy to use the app has
one button you tap to it to connect and
it's as simple as that stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy
protect yourself at
expressvpn.com Matt Walsh show use my
Link at expressvpn.com to get three
extra months free that's EXP
ressvpn.com Matt Walsh show in this case
once again he looks in her general
direction from what might add up to like
one and a half seconds total although
she slows down the she puts it in slow
motion
to make it seem longer
and this makes him a pervert deserving
of public shaming
he glances over at a woman
taking her shirt off whether or not
that's the reason he glanced she decided
to do that and that's he makes he's a
pervert now because of that
now let me just make a few points here
first there are many reasons why a
person might look in your direction
while you're out in public
these women because they're raging
narcissists with a severely inflated
sense of their own importance and their
own physical attractiveness just assume
that any person who looks at them must
be admiring their beauty but
particularly in the in the first video I
can easily imagine several other
possible explanations he might have been
looking because he was wondering why the
woman was filming and muttering to
herself like a schizophrenic he might
have been feeling self-conscious because
he knew that he was probably in the
background of her shot
he might have been thinking to himself
she's not filming me is she
and turns out she was
or he might have been glancing over
because he wanted to turn with the
equipment that she was using and was
waiting for his chance to swoop in as
soon as she moved on okay he may have
been frustrated because he's trying to
get his workout in and he's got this
woman sitting there filming a social
media video with the damn equipment he
wants to use
you know that's that that is something
that happens I had this experience at
the gym over the past weekend I was
using one of the benches over the
dumbbell station while there was a guy
who's kind of lingering in the
background staring over at it was just
me there are other people using the
benches and he's like staring over and
continuously sort of you know looking
and then you look back and I didn't
assume
that he was looking at me because of my
striking good looks I also I didn't even
assume that he was looking at me and
thinking hey isn't that the what is a
woman guy the latter possibility was
much more likely than the former but
instead I assumed that he wanted to use
the bench that I was using
and uh then I got up and he staked his
claim to it as soon as I was done
confirming my theory so this is all very
normal and fine in a gym it's what
people do and nobody has to be publicly
shamed over but let's say that in the
case of these women
the offending men really were looking
over at least in part because they found
the women physically attractive
so what
okay that still would not constitute
harassment much less would it make them
perverts it would just make them normal
men whose only sin is merely noticing a
woman
this doesn't make them you know this
doesn't make doesn't make them harassers
doesn't make them perverts it just makes
them men with functioning eyes is what
is all it does
second thing here's a tip if you're a
woman
and you don't want to be noticed by men
if indeed even the brief glance of a man
offends you and causes trauma
then you might consider wearing clothing
when you go out in public
now I'm not saying you need to cover
yourself in a burlap sack or hit the gym
in a parka and snow pants but I am
saying that you probably want to wear
more than just your underwear
so both women are working out in skimpy
spandex shorts and a sports bra a
uniform that has become by the way quite
common at gyms all across the country at
some point in the past few years the
nation's women decided by majority vote
I guess that clothes are optional when
working out in public and yeah according
to the laws in most States apparently
they're free to treat the gym like a
nudist resort if they so choose but
they're not free to control everyone
else's minds and eyeballs while they
perform a striptease at Planet Fitness
the woman in the second video she
actually strips down to her underwear in
the middle of the gym
they have locker rooms for that purpose
but she chose to do it in public
perhaps next she'll give herself a
sponge bath while standing on the
treadmill I mean who knows the thing is
you don't behave this way and dress like
that unless you want attention
you can claim otherwise but you're lying
you dress that way because you want
attention period
there is no other possible motivation
for walking around in public in your
underwear if anyone does that man or
woman you're looking for attention
depending on
what you look like and whether you're a
man or a woman and all the rest of it
it'll determine what sort of attention
you get but you're going to get
attention if you walk around in your
underwear
If any man you know men don't do that do
you notice that men aren't rolling up to
the gym in their underwear like when's
the last time you saw a man at the gym
wearing just box or shorts and nothing
else
I've never seen it
but guess what if a man did do that
people would be stuck women would be
staring
maybe because they find them attractive
or maybe because they're thinking what
the hell is that guy wearing to the gym
but here's the thing with these with
these women they want to control they
want the attention they want the
attention but they want to control
exactly what sort of attention they
receive and from whom and for how long
and in what way they want attention but
it must be a tension that fits their
mood at any given moment and that's just
not how this works okay life does not
work that way no matter how much you
wanted to it doesn't if you go out in
public and say hey everyone look at me
they're going to look and you're not
going to get to control who looks for
how long all the rest of it
speaking of trying to control the type
of attention keep in mind that these
women are recording their workouts to
put on social media they're supposedly
self-conscious about being watched yet
they're posting the footage to the
Internet so that thousands of people can
watch it
they don't want to be noticed while they
work out so they work out in their
underwear on camera
there seems to be a logical disconnect
here
but it's a symptom of the disease that
we just talked about people these days
not just women on Tick Tock though
especially them perhaps are desperate
for attention they're starving for it
all the time and yet while going out of
their way to solicit the attention of
countless strangers they still think
they should be able to control the
manner and duration of the attention
most of all they want all the attention
to come through a screen
so they're standing in a room with other
human beings
demanding the attention of everyone who
isn't in the room while wishing to be
invisible to everybody in the room
if anything is perverse it's that
attitude
finally ladies
if you're wondering why you aren't
meeting any decent men out there it
might have something to do with this it
might be because they're afraid of being
publicly shamed as rapists if they even
so much as glance in your direction or
God forbid try to speak to you
if a man could potentially be a pervert
simply for noticing your presence in a
room
if he commits harassment by trying to
initiate any kind of conversation or
interaction at all then the game is
hopelessly rigged against him and he
loses automatically
more and more men will decide just not
to play the game it's not worth the risk
and that's exactly what's happened
and that is why
and that's all Happening by the way
thanks to women like Jessica and Adriana
and that is why they in particular are
the ones who are today canceled that'll
do it for this portion of the show let's
move over to the members block if you're
not a member you can become a member
today use code Walsh at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed foreign
[Music]
[Applause]